look at us
four killers
in album mode
i have too much momentum
season two girls by bubba is in album
mode we have a record deal and we are
going to create the most amazing album
ever it feels like just yesterday we are
trying to sing in a mall this season is
when they really let it rip it's go time
for the girls
[Music]
in season two you can expect more warmth
and heart so many great songs and as
always so much comedy done please spit
take on my behalf
how did i do that i'm not drinking
anything this is the first album they're
doing on their own so they are trying to
find their voice we need the album done
in six weeks that's fast we're under the
gun we have some power struggles if you
wanted the solo i didn't you just come
out and say it even paul lets george do
his own thing sometimes because paul
george is one basketball man dawn you're
not making sense each one of them is
still falling and getting up in their
personal life timothy
how'd you find me you geotagged your
apartment
it's more of the journey of finding not
just their friendship and their talent
but also themselves
you're growing you know i'm only doing
vocal fry now if i'm scared or i need
something that's huge
i think one of the best parts of the
show is that we have a cast that can
sing all this absurd nonsense that we
throw at them
[Music]
the songs are so catchy they're so funny
it's really just a pleasure to get to
play
[Music]
it is a good time every day certainly
with this cast they are the most
talented and tight friends and it comes
across and i think that's probably one
of the successes of the show
look how far we've come to sing music
that
we
i
made
like all great girl groups
together they kind of make this perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is beauty it's brown mountain k-cup
sparkling champ brown don't drink it
it's just for holding up
[Music]
you